the story of how we proposed was we were
down at Beachcomber restaurant a great
little restaurant for breakfast in
Orange County California and I had
purchased the ring already obviously and
you know I had known Elisa since we were
10 or 11 years old so what's amazing
about it is you still get extremely
nervous and so we go down for breakfast
I said I can't make it through breakfast
if I don't pop this question now so
Elisa goes she's like oh man I'm gonna
go use the restroom you know where we
just gotten down there and I said not
the most romantic way to set it up I
guess and I said okay and I walked a
little further down the beach while we
were waiting for our table and Elisa
only began to expect it
when she saw how far down the beach I
was because I didn't want to be around a
bunch of people and you know and then
just got down to 1A pop the question and
it was lovely it's really great and we
had breakfast then uh it was just a
great it was a marvelous
that's what that's all I have to say
about that